foreign
[Music]
just about everyone should be familiar
with the Planet of the Apes movie series
whether it's the classic movie from 1968
and its sequels or the three somewhat
more modern reboots from the 2010s there
is something for nearly everyone's taste
after the dark and very popular war of
the Planet of the Apes from 2017. we can
soon look forward to a new release we
tell you everything you need to know
about the upcoming action spectacle and
hope you enjoy our new original episode
as usual there is a possibility of
spoilers regarding the previous films so
be warned we can expect the story of
kingdom of the Planet of the Apes will
follow more or less directly from its
predecessor we recall at the end of the
third movie main character Caesar
succumbs to his wounds after saving his
tribe and defending it against an army
of humans shortly before he passes away
the orangutan Maurice assures him that
his son Cornelius will learn his
father's name thus passing on his rule
as well Caesar had previously led him
and many other Apes to an oasis giving
them a chance to survive in the hostile
environment War of the Planet of the
Apes was already rather dark and
emotional which fits perfectly with
Caesar's quest for Revenge which he
undertakes after his wife and son were
murdered by humans it can be assumed
that Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes
will likewise follow a similar pattern
as we already know from a first plot
description by deadline based on this
the movie will take place sometime after
the events of his predecessor as
revealed by a casting report the film
which will be released in 2024 will
feature several ape communities that
have emerged from the Oasis us while a
small group of humans have slowly
recovered from the ape flu Caesar's
Legacy is said to be ambivalent while
some ape communities have never even
heard of the hero others turn history in
their favor and established their own
Empires based on false facts due to this
we can assume that some time will have
passed between part 3 and part 4. one of
the many ape leaders is said to be
particularly ruthless and enslave other
Apes for his own purposes in order to
gain access to human technology the main
protagonist probably Cornelius fights
with all means for the freedom of all
apes and against their enslavement along
the way he meets a young human woman who
accompanies him but also has her own
interests it is not yet known whether
she like many of her kind has become
mute due to the flu as soon as we have
more details about the story of kingdom
of the Planet of the Apes we will keep
you posted
regarding the cast of Planet of the Apes
4 there is already some info thus for
example we will see Caesar's son
Cornelius again will be played by Black
Mirror actor Owen Teague apart from him
there are many confirmed actors with
unknown roles including newcomer Travis
Jeffrey the winter star Freya Allen the
Orville actor Peter Makin Jessica Jones
actor Ika darville and Kevin Durant who
played a part in the butterfly effect in
February The Hollywood Reporter also
revealed that Jurassic world Dominion
actress Daikin lochman and Shameless
star William H Macy would be joining the
cast there is speculation that Macy will
take on the role of the villain which
would put him in good company with David
oyelowo Gary Oldman and Woody Harrelson
from the previous films it is considered
almost certain that Freya Allen will
play the protagonist's human companion
while Durant and Macon are believed to
play Apes for the other actors it is
unclear which side their characters will
be on filming on Kingdom of the Planet
of the Apes began in October 2022 in
Sydney Australia under the working title
forbidden zone and was already concluded
in mid February 2023 the director this
time is Wes ball after Rupert Wyatt was
in charge of the first part and the
Batman director Matt Reeves directed the
following two sequels this is the first
time since Maze Runner 3 from 2018 that
ball has been back in the director's
chair the screenplay which was also
penned by ball was also contributed by
Avatar 2 writer Josh Friedman according
to Caesar actor Andy Circus director
West ball is the perfect man for the job
he promised wholeheartedly that the end
result would blow the audience away we
can't wait to see if the movie can keep
that promise
apart from some artwork there has been
much to see from the project yet neither
is there official news about the first
trailer so far since filming has been
done for more than three months many
fans would like to see at least a first
trailer however one should not disregard
the fact the complex editing of the
footage has just begun after the
shooting was over with such a special
effects heavy movie that can definitely
take some time the previous movies are
considered Milestones of the performance
capture technique and the realistic
portrayal of the Apes and their emotions
always caused Great astonishment among
the audience it is to be expected that
the new movie will strive for a similar
quality the final result can be seen
next year Kingdom of the Planet of the
Apes is slated for a theatrical release
on May 24 2024
please leave us a thumbs up if you like
this video also let us know in the
comments if you think the film series
has a shot at matching the success of
its predecessor even without Andy Circus
in the leading role thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]